yeah but like i've been camping quite a
bit in australia like my dad and i used
to go camping all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] camper power outlet with the
[ __ ] yeah exactly but like i
i realized okay japan does not know how
to go camping
because like it really is it really is
baby mode on mario
so we we saw someone like so like we had
like some relatively small tents right
were you neighbors yeah we had neighbors
yeah that's yeah that's that's the thing
that really put me off because i thought
we it was
but it was one lot apart because there
were social distances it was one lot of
play it was
one thing i learned about a tent is that
it's just not noise proof at
all i can hear [ __ ] everything
literally i remember we were sleeping
and i just
i could hear like the other tent [ __ ]
farting in the background
i'm just like okay who was that was that
you nabi okay whatever
but like some of these tents that these
people bought they weren't [ __ ] tense
so some of our neighbors right um one
one lots like
like two lots down from us they they
start unpacking this tent
right and then they this tent has
[ __ ] compartments right
and then not only that you you i
remember walking past they had an
entrance
right they had an entrance that had
lights on the entrance
okay and like fairy lights and this tent
had like
two [ __ ] bedrooms a living room oh my
god my parents
don't like that yeah and has that even a
tent though yeah it's like a family time
it's just a pop-up apartment
yeah but it's like a family tent i'm
just i'm just like this isn't a ten this
is a two ldk
bro like jesus tents are a [ __ ]
nightmare to shut up yeah
well but that's the thing right it's
like i get it if it was a family but
this was a couple
this is a couple yeah that's ridiculous
yeah unlike that time because you're a
japanese couple so naturally you're not
gonna sleep in the same bag
of course i was getting to that because
this this like this tent had
carpet had shelves and i'm just like
might as well just like bring a [ __ ]
caravan
at this point we'd take that but we
stayed for like three weeks
that makes sense if it's three weeks
they stayed for a single night and like
of course okay so here's like the single
night yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they
they came with us and they left them so
so here's the premium japanese couple
experience that i saw right so we walked
past this tent right
and of course this japanese couple you
know obviously
very intimate japanese couple to be
going on a camping trip by themselves
together very intimate very intimate so
the peak japanese couple experience was
seeing the guy next to his car on a
[ __ ] gamer chair or something
and then seeing the girl on the other
side of this massive
tent on a hammock both of them by
themselves not interacting
premium japanese couple experience i
mean isn't that love
yeah that's love no i i mean i say it's
the premium japanese couple experience
because
the amount of times like we've gone to
like onsens or ryokans or something and
like
it's just like us the boys and we're
just surrounded by japanese couples they
don't talk to each other not talking to
you they don't talk to you just not
interacting with each other couples that
social distance together
stay together you know they're just
social distancing yeah